I heard that orson welles patterned his
Unicron character after Marion Davies
vagina the ship is currently on a
trajectory towards a planet known as
totally not the Death Star at all an
educated robot populace still uses
escalator slaves also why the hell would
robots need shopping malls was there a
version of Abercrombie & Fitch for the
yuppie BOTS is there a robot topic for
goth bots nobody in this futuristic
transformer society who watches the
skies for a living saw this huge ass
planet ship coming toward their planet
the only unique feature of this
incredibly obvious Death Star ripoff is
that it sucks things up into its
weaponized butthole
unicron's thresher sounds exactly like
the 40 year old dude two rows in front
of me eating double fist fulls of his
large buttered popcorn with Junior Mints
sprinkles on the title is actually the
Transformers the movie the hell sense
does that make
I guess the screenwriter charge by the
letter cuz hey that laserdisc players
not gonna pay for itself just when nine
year old me was about to strip this
movie's title of being the Citizen Kane
of animated robot movies the opening
credits hit me with the wall up listen I
love the theme song as much as anyone
but this movie is 79 minutes long and
covers a lot of ground and they still
decided to literally play the entire
glam metal version it is the year 2005
the treacherous Decepticons have
conquered the Autobots home planet
there's also this fellow named $0.50 on
the radio that can't stop talking about
how many times he's been shot I'm pretty
sure nobody explains how Laser bkt
septic on spy bird was able to fly into
this moon base undetected I want you to
make a special run to on earth wait help
encloses earth to the Autobots home
planet
even if Ironhide were able to move as
fast as a normal spaceship it'd probably
take a while to get there let alone a
roundtrip number now just a crease let's
disappear racist sound waves playback
laser beeps findings
playing back laserbeak's footage
requires a decepticon with a video deck
a huge USB r2d2 connector of some sort
and practically an entire mini model
spaceship port at crazy 2005 technology
man also the universe that has
transforming robots and intergalactic
space travel is also still dependent on
VHS tapes
Laserbeak was able to set up about seven
different camera angles when he compiled
a spy footage also where is camera to
get this shot Laserbeak would be in full
view of Optimus I mean look how close to
iron-hard space he is even though these
are robots and could survive the cold
vacuum of space it's still looking
vacuum these assholes should have been
sucked out of the ship as soon as
Megatron breached the whole Megatron who
clearly has an awesome laser blasting
cannon attached to himself simply
changes into a big gun for some other
asshole to use the Autobots were clearly
trained at the finest stormtrooper
aiming school and are proud to show off
their skills whenever they man the refs
missed one there
Megatron should have been immediately
flying for expositional taunting the
trans fishing the movie fish you're
jumping today huh no hard to tell
considering the person in charge of
focusing the shot must have been on a
massive dose of quaaludes judging by the
scope of Daniels locator it could be
landing at any location in the northern
hemisphere
Daniel unwittingly hoverboards through
the Battletoads wind tunnel level if
you're gonna ride Dino
ride and static also just leave that
probably expensive piece of futuristic
awesomeness back in the wilderness why
settle for a peek Daniel but you can see
everything from Lookout Mountain
I guess Autobot City is roughly around
Chattanooga this Decepticon has hotrod
in his sights but weeks just long enough
for this dickhead to stop him okay I
realize this is a cartoon I really do
but these Autobots have distinct
abilities right and Hunt rod is a
fucking sports car but can somehow
easily make it down this unpaved
Mountain blur aka the Micro Machines guy
aka John will she - jr. inspires
dickhead to pick a YouTube channel 26
years later
hot rod and cup or driving on a narrow
road beside a mountain and the flying
Decepticons still can't shoot them
[Music]
realizing how terrible is blaster name
is Starscream decides to try and insult
these two to death but I know they're
transforming an entire city and all but
it takes forever like arming the Death
Star forever
shouldn't they go to a more immediate
option if they're already under attack
these Decepticons use these extremely
useful insecticons who can eat through
metal only one time and don't bring more
of them
get this motherfucker fly cuz he hanging
on to a bridge for Megatron just ordered
these bug assholes to breach the
defenses but once they did he allows
this gaping hole to go unguarded and on
enter
luckily the Autobots have a second door
behind their main door just in case the
first one gets chewed up by insecticons
movie 1980s so hard that it required at
least one transformer on each side to be
able to turn into a ghetto blaster do
you think you got surprised why the hell
do you fade to black here before coming
back to the exact same battle did they
get confused and think there was gonna
be a commercial break coming but there
are treads and wheels on that machine so
shouldn't they be able to I don't know
drive it into place
did it affect it what the launcher is in
a slightly different position than it
was when these assholes arrived it's
almost like some kind of Voltron of some
sort lasers guns robots excitement
Dinobots
why did they need the Dinobots on this
mission is because they needed to get
all the toys they've ever made up in
this fucking movie at this point I'm
half expecting to see a random go bot
[Music]
I think the song was sung by Dirk
Diggler using the equally poor new
moniker Stan Bush Stan these Decepticons
are the slowest attacking us
motherfuckers ever
this battles been raging all night and
Optimus and his crew just got here for
reinforcements but these quads are
standing in the same place they've been
for the last five movie minutes come on
even robots don't think about shooting
up the goddamn tires one shall stand one
shall fall optimises most glaring
weakness is to dramatically announce his
entrance before fight to the death
yeah because there's such an honor code
with Transformers when it comes to these
fights if hot rod helps and Megatron is
defeated he will get such a grounding
[Music]
this Transformers movie said your
childhood do all the kids my age
Autobots are seriously unable to hit an
enormous Decepticon carrying another
wounded Decepticon even though they're
not returning fire do not grieve I'll be
resurrected in roughly twenty years just
in time to see Megan Fox at her prime
but one day an Autobot shall rise from
our ranks old character spouts prophecy
won't die in cliche Autobots up for a
straight black-and-white i G filter when
they died while Decepticons opt for more
of a sepia tone are we supposed to
believe Unicron has some sort of God's
eye view of everything in the universe
or is this another Laserbeak thing can
they build the Devastator inside the
spaceship hmm wait was Unicron looking
for the abandon Decepticons or is this
we're almost dead Decepticons end up in
some sort of Dante's Inferno scenario it
really doesn't pay me that this was
Orson Welles last performance since aw
I'm sure he was paid well but the fact
that his heavily processed voice is
coming out of an animated robotic space
butthole makes me view touch of evil
through a slightly different lens fund
IDs summons something that is
practically dead and floating in space
is there some sort of auto summoning
signal are these guys hooked up via
Skynet or some point is he's dead and
that matrix died with him
the point is but with that said you are
the best evil robot I can get to do this
for me what is it about Unicron that
makes him able to do this he's a planet
devouring robot sure but he can also
retrofit Megatron with a new suit and
new weaponry also the Unicron does
nothing to make Megatron smarter
he's got carte blanche to make the best
robot slave ever and he ends up making
Megatron legacy way too many seconds of
this scooch attractive I just wanna do
sweeps
after reading this scene in the script
it was probably difficult for the Hasbro
executives to hide their boners
considering they just introduced a
million new toys also the powerful
Unicron who we saw suck a planet dry at
the beginning of the movie needs to
create minions to destroy the matrix of
leadership rather than simply go to
earth and do it himself what a dumb ass
I will rip open Ultra Magnus and every
other Autobots apparently if you can
upgrade from Unicron he throws in a new
famous voice free of charge rather than
spending several minutes introducing
Megatron's new posse I would much rather
see how Starscream won that fight to see
who would lead the Decepticons so the
movie has eliminated two of the
franchise leads within roughly the first
30 minutes of the movie which is
definitely what everyone paid for when
they bought a ticket back in 1986 just a
minute ago you needed a whole fucking
station to try and send a message to
Optimus Prime but now you can receive
faint signals by yourself
[Music]
thus premature celebration is done
before they even look back at Unicron
making it so premature that they should
have started it back on the moon base
[Music]
Looby tries to justify its PG rating
with a tiny bit of salty language when
it already earned that by killing off
cast Unicron created Galvatron but could
not fix his insubordination Java will
crush you just as trying just like
Megatron wait how the hell did altra
Magnus hear Galvatron say anything
though all the robots have those
Avengers communicators built-in this is
one of the very few funny parts in this
movie but I'm wondering why the Dinobots
not only hadn't been helping with the
battle but need to be boosted up into
the fucking shuttle transformed back
into robots assholes
Grimlock of the retro rabbit again
excerpts from John Stein BOTS of mice
and Autobots Ultra Magnus subscribes to
the everyone left behind that's not
currently on this ship philosophy also
during this entire take off the
Decepticons missed the ship and Arcee
with every single shot they take that
was close you keep your ping liar
congratulations Autobots we've lost the
Decepticons were literally right on top
of them as they were lifting off and
they headed straight for space up behind
some asteroid I guess Galvatron took
some time off to shoot some nudes or
something more casual Star Wars thievery
comedy hot rod just bought it and I just
bought cup and hot rod wait did I get
suckered by subliminal advertising again
dammit somehow Magnus performs this
trick without the Decepticons noticing
these missiles hit the ship then
apparently go inside and make coffee use
the restroom and then blow up and the
matrix with them Unicron can cause
long-distance pain to Galvatron but
simply can't send him a message that he
didn't destroy the matrix
transformers movie suddenly turns into
an episode of full house the last time
we saw a couple hot rod they were
crashing onto this seemingly all metal
planet that did not appear to have any
large bodies of water on it but okay
sure feel like we're just playing a
level of Megaman at this point these
Fischer robots right so why are they
eating the other fish why would any
robots eat you don't see Ultra Magnus
chomping on a sandwich do you how stupid
is it that there is a robe over j'en of
everything hey guys what if there's this
planet where everything is the same as
it is on earth but the plants and
animals are robots somehow evolved the
exact same way they did on earth only
robots you know if I have a made it
clear that they're robots yet talk to me
hey just because these guys are robots
doesn't mean they get to talk normally
underwater I mean look at this guy there
are bubbles coming out of his mouth
why didn't he sound like I think Daniel
can make himself useful with this damn
RC he's pretty young for a sex room it
was spikes exosuit Oh dad's exosuit he
told me all about it I can totally wear
that my dad and I are the same height we
both loved my mom in the very same way
offer expires while you're white voice
actor who receives top billing for this
movie doesn't appear until almost 50
minutes into it that does it well what
do you think well hot rod I can see that
you used your tools to fix me but I
still can't quit put my finger on whan
you gave me that blow job in the middle
of it now let's find that Dinobots and
get him off his twisted planet how do
you know that the Dinobots aren't in the
underwater hell you just came from did
they get that separated from the
Dinobots I use the universal greeting
Universal greeting if this greeting is
so Universal and rod would presumably
also know it
oh now some of our heroes are imperiling
oh yeah we forgot about Galvatron and
Unicron and the fact that Optimus is
dead and Daniel's father is most likely
dead let's spend some time on some robot
shark planet who's Unicron cranek stays
alive only long enough for some helpful
exposition why Boyd Boyd oh god damn I
wish this movie would make up its mind
about whether it's four five year olds
or fifteen year olds
why is this asshole not won yet ultra-
is dead and the matrix destroyed Jesus
Christ
the scene where Calvin thought he beat
Ultra Magnus happened 11 minutes ago in
movie time and I just want a hammer home
that Unicron Dragon Galvatron all the
way back here just to tell him he didn't
is the stupidest thing I've seen in any
transformers film ever including the
Michael Bay once matrix has not been
destroyed and own tremendous moves and
the planet of junk once again if Unicron
was so concerned about there why didn't
he scoot over to the dirt mall planet
and suck it up then Decepticons
we made alright it's shocking that the
robots that were just recently following
you have now followed you to where you
land it also what the hell Galvatron
went all the way back to Unicron then
all the way back to the junk planet and
all the Autobots have had time to do is
weld a couple of pieces back on the ship
I thought space was big and stuff man
these Autobots are the absolute worst at
leaving people behind two armed robots
are taken out by what appears to be a
Roomba also if this suit transforms so
dramatically I can only imagine that
Daniels limbs have all been severed
during the transition and he's in severe
shock right now
attack be sure to be ludicrously
ineffective just like we've been this
entire movie prime you said the matrix
would light our darkest hour he's also
dead so you can see we're believing in
things got him these shark things
evolved to have tails shaped like maces
which makes them menacing sure but it's
probably hell on their swimming
abilities this escape scene is such a
feat of physics that I'm surprised
Galileo Newton and Einstein didn't rise
from the dead to destroy Hasbro good
these slowly moving dinosaurs are here
to literally exmark another situation I
hear this is also a slang term for robot
lesbian sex
[Music]
I want to remove us in for a movie
playing a weird al' yankovic song but
during an action scene okay so Daniel
knocks this guy out with a steel beam
and suddenly there's no danger anymore a
minute ago Daniel said and sure enough
they were everywhere this helicopter guy
took care of one or two of them but
we're still a lot after that I guess the
rest were killed by editor David Hankins
how in the ever-loving did hot rotten
Cup know where the other Autobots were
this is an entirely different planet
[Music]
Weird Al Yankovic would be amazing at
cinemasins
at one point this movie's title was the
Transformers b-movie the electric
Boogaloo the art the Optimus Prime were
alive to see Ultra Magnus get
resurrected from the dead
where's Galvatron where is he Unicron
mother would wreck our know this feel
like half this movie's plot is based on
robots being able to sense where other
robots are what a time considered
bedding or changing a planet Cybertron
wouldn't have been easier for Unicron
Cybertron up in its normal planets
drawing form this transformation seems
unnecessary unless you're trying to sell
a toy or saw oh no this is how gravity
works in space gets all these
transformers transformed into fast modes
of transportation but they decide
running is the best option against the
rapidly advancing debt clause
it cannot be opened not by a Decepticon
also not by an Autobot considering ultra
Magnus's impotent attempt destroyed
we just hope to be obliterated master
FINA cron can still control Galvatron
then he should be able to make him
destroy the matrix although we don't
know what would happen if he destroyed
the matrix because movie doesn't tell us
but it'd be really bad
Dinobots our way to prominently featured
in a battle that involves an inhibited
planet several high functioning Autobots
and a magical silly thing that has super
abilities and stuff by the way these
flying down a lot so the same Dinobots
who couldn't get their dumb asses on the
ship earlier because of something
something run time why not transform
into the car at all times during these
things
why do transformers and humans inside
transformers put up with this running I
mean did they just rupture Unicron
splatter stupid crockpot of death that
hasn't factored into the movie at all is
now featured to add some unnecessary
drama to the end of the movie remove 50
sins right now of his dad tripped and
fell into the acid anyway satisfaction
[Music]
also geez this matrix of leadership
thing is a dick waited until just now to
activate also considering how hot rod
escapes the situation solely by
something magical being close to him
it's clear the Transformers
unintentionally inspired the end of
every Harry Potter movie I didn't a porn
star ever use this name also here's some
more bullshit with the matrix of
leadership are you telling me you have
to guess who's worthy of the matrix
before it'll work how do you do that do
you need to conduct American Ninja
Warrior trials or something or just hope
you luck out like this light the matrix
of leadership is basically just more
infuriating kryptonite taking down a
character there's way too powerful for
his own good
Unicron should have won this an hour ago
when nobody knew how to operate it
shouldn't both of his eyes be emitting a
green light right now since his left eye
was also damaged what this mark the end
of the Cybertronian Wars as we march
forward to a new age of peace and
happiness so everything's okay then we
don't need like five live-action movies
in the future Jeff was still alive
it's a whopper all right scooch the
trekker2 sweeps cyclonus warrior and
diesel late Laser laser freedom to the
shock economies you know I have one
simple request and that is to have
sharks with frickin laser beams attached
to their heads
[Music]
it's mega mate
you must know something about the
prophecy no I'm doing my best but I know
the prophecy I made it up
Autobots prepare to board the shuttles
this new menace is more dangerous than
all the Decepticons put together
I want that camper torn apart Oh cavity
searchers all around I use the universal
greeting universal greeting where's my
dad that's what we're gonna find out and
knowing is half the battle
[Applause]
[Music]